les jours
alors monsieur cousin marseille gaspard
proust un baltringue est parisienne oui
monsieur additionne ces summer et on
s'adapte avait l'accent c'est plus
marrant disponibilité gentillesse
flexibilité mais surtout un esprit
comique affûté de la tête coquillettes
aujourd'hui j'aimerais dédicacé ma
rubrique à marseille la belle rebelle
mondialement connue pour être la plaque
tournante du chômage internationale
est-ce que marseille beaucoup apprendre
la france marseille c'est une mosaïque
de diversité des différences de nos
similitudes d'antithèse de
contradictions de contraste de
disparités disproportion de dissemblance
de dissimilitude de distance de
distinction de diverger ans d'écart
d'hétérogénéité des compatibilités d'une
égalité des nuances de variétés et c'est
là où s'arrête demain dictionnaire des
synonymes
autour de ma vie le tout est ambiance
des raisons et surprise tient au débotté
d'une rue qu'est ce donc que cet
attroupement de métro sexuel prostituée
qui s'ignore et de salariés triste mais
bon ça c'est bien sûr c'est le plateau
de plus belle la vie
voici donc quelques conseils pour passer
un bel été l'été c'est le thème des
noyades bon
quand vous voyez un homme qui est dans
une piscine ou à la mer et qui crient
s'il vous plaît attention c'est pas
forcément un rom
ces gens là n'ont pas le monopole de la
politesse
non peut-être que la personne vous
montrer qu'elle aime être regardée comme
tu es le cool
respecté dit tu coules c'est cool
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs
il se peut que ce soit c'est rare mais
bon un appel au secours et que vous ne
savez pas l'âge et se pose une question
qu'est ce que vous foutez la plage
un tellement que de lucidité sur ses
propres
aptitudes
devrait vous faire quitter immédiatement
les lieux foutu le prévenir les secours
bien sûr que non sinon comment ils
s'affûte ces gens là on n'exerce pas la
truffe du cochon truffier en lui
montrant où elle se trouve
le rôle des secours c'est de deviner ce
qui peut se passer respecter ce travail
mais l'été c'est aussi le soleil on dit
qu'il faut se protéger balivernes
bagatelle e billevesées calembredaines
coquecigrues fadaises de fariboles
niaiseries et sornettes et c'est là où
s'arrête le mans dictionnaire des
synonymes
autre conseil de vacances
les moustiques problème avec les
moustiques c'est que comme prennent pas
ces curieux patron il faut des
représailles mais comme dirait notre
ministre de la justice à la [ __ ] oui
mais d'injustice
aux côtés moustiques que vous attaquez
soyez vigilants soyez à l'écouté
chercher à deviner ses trajectoires
compte et mentalement le nombre de ses
battements d'aile pour évaluer le poids
il va venir vous piquer et dans combien
de temps et 20 banques la trappe boom
immédiatement tu lui suce le sang qui
vient de bois tuyaux crache à la gueule
et tu dis c'est pas bien ce que tu as
fait
certes la violence ne résout pas tous
les problèmes mais elle al'avantage de
diminuer le nombre de personnes qui la
cause
entre méfiance de l'été
les enfants toujours laissé sans
surveillance mais qui gambadent les
pauvres couillons qui se perdent eux qui
prennent la route ces [ __ ] plus haut
à hesdin kenzan croiront que le bas que
leur ouvrira les portes d'un cerf [ __ ]
des générations qu'ils aillent se faire
enlever vers des contrées comme la
belgique oui si le secours populaire
permet à de nombreux enfants du nord de
rejoindre les plages du sud la
pédophilie permet à de nombreux enfants
du sud de visiter les caves du ans
mais bien sûr
cela s'appelle la curiosité
intellectuelle
et il vaut mieux commencer tout
autres petites choses qui peuvent
arriver et me collent ceux des plages
faut-il en avoir peur la réponse de
bernard de la villardière est très clair
si c'était me cause de droite ça me
plaît
plus sérieusement un bien sûr faut pas
avoir peur
mais non c'est le début
une mycose c'est quand même la
possibilité d'avoir un animal de
compagnie à faible coût et d'une
fidélité sans faille mycoses au pied tu
n'as pas bouger
les limicoles je pense tongs mais on ne
dit pas tango mais claquettes l'attend
golf et un moule à craquer tous ses
claques
japy tanks
toujours à pratiquer sous un soleil
torride l'éternel problème de la
pétanque le cochonnet à ne pas confondre
avec la boules de geisha la balle du
people où sa femme car attention si
pierre qui roule n'amasse pas mousse la
femme qui rit bundy fini dans les orties
[Applaudissements]
je termine par un petit sondage sondage
d'été il paraît que les françaises
veulent valls pour une nuit montebourg
pour les vacances et j'ajouterais sa
peine pour l'éternité
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux